know that you said you know anyone that
you're seen with that they think you're
dating we actually had a great interview
recently
um and um they all these articles came
out about our amazing chemistry and I
was like you have to do that right yeah
well there you go but then I thought you
have to be dead inside if you don't have
amazing chemistry with Brad Pitt so I
think that probably happens a lot but
when you do go out do you go out
Incognito like how do you disguise
yourself I'm very covert
just uh I'm kind of like the shark I
just keep moving
[Applause]
you know it's a minute you stop is it
the motorcycle helmet like
like that's really good yeah that's a
good one except when you get into a
restaurant you got to take it off or
have a crash which did happen yeah that
happens too